ننتقل الان الى السودان حيث قال مراسل
الجزيره ان دويا في جارات متتاليه وعنيفه
سمع جنوب ام درمان وكان مراسل الجزيره قد
افاد في وقت سابق بتجدد القصف المدفعي
مترافقا مع تحليق للطيران الحربي في سماء
العاصمه الخرطوم من هناك ينضم الينا
مراسلنا الطاهر المرضي ليضعنا في صوره اخر
التطورات الطهر
نعم اخر التطورات هو انخفضت حده هذه
المعارك التي كانت في الصباح الباكر
واستخدمت فيها المدافع والاسلحه الثقيله
والطيران في غرب ام درمان وفي وسط الخرطوم
كذلك وفي الشارع الغابه وفي الخرطوم
والجنوب التي دوت فيها المدافع في اتجاه
معسكرات لقوات الدعم السريع جنوبا ثم
هنالك في الخرطوم البحري وبعض المناطق كان
ذلك في الصباح الباكر حتى منتصف النهار
ولكن حده المعارك هذه انخفضت الان بشكل
ملحوظ ولا نسمع في جنوب الخرطوم اي نوع من
الانفجار او تحليق للطيران هذا هو الوضع
ولكن الوضع في دارفور يبدو اكثر تعقيدا
خاصه وفي ولايه غرب دارفور في منطقه
الجنينه كانت هنالك معارك وكانت هنالك
ايضا ازمه انسانيه وان عدد جرحى يفوق
الاثنين الف جريح وان الاوضاع الانسانيه
والظروف الصحيه منهاره او الوضع الصحي
منهار وانقطاع للكهرباء والمياه
والاتصالات وخروج لمنظمات الانسانيه هذا
عقد المشهد بشكل كبير مما جعل النقابه
الاطباء في هذه الولايه الى اطلاق مناشدات
او الناشده العالم لانقاذ الوضع بشكل عاجل
هذا الوضع كان وضع مماثل له في مدينه كتم
التي تتبع لولايه شمال دارفور حيث دارت
معارك هناك وعدد من المشردين والقتله
والجرحى في هذه المناطق هذه هي الوضع
الميداني هذا هو الوضع العسكري بشكله
الحالي في ظل عدم وجود اي نوع من الالتزام
من الجيش السوداني او القوات الدعم السريع
بوقف لاطلاق النار او خفض اي نوع من هذا
التصعيد او الابتعاد حتى من مواقع
المدنيين هنالك قلق لدى المدنيين بان عدم
وجود اي نوع من المفاوضات سيؤثر سلبا على
الاوضاع الانسانيه عن هذه المحاضر والحديث
وما تحدث عنه عبد الفتاح البرهان وتلك
الشروط حتى ينجح منبر جده كما قال
نعم الان انا اسمع اطلاق اصوات قويه من
المدافع من جنوب الخرطوم
في هذه اللحظات
نعم
الاتصال اتصال وزير خارجيه اليوم برئيس
مجلس السياده القائد العام للجيش السوداني
هذه خطوه لبعض يرى انها يمكن ان تكون خطوه
ايجابيه ولكن الذي رشح من هذه
المحادثه الهاتفيه هو ان البرهان طالب ان
يلتزم وتلتزم قوات الدعم السريع بالخروج
من المنازل ومن المؤسسات الصحيه ومن
المرافق المدنيه
وان تزيل الارتكازات الموجوده على الطريق
هذا ما قاله لوزير الخارجيه السعودي وحتى
تنجح اي نوع من الهدنه او اي نوع من
الاتفاق ولكن لا نعلم اذا كان هنالك اتفاق
على استئناف المفاوضات في اي موعد لاحق لم
يعلم بعد شكرا جزيلا لك الطاهر المرضي من
الخرطوم